[Aplausos]
[Música]
siempre bordeando la legalidad donald
trump no es un tipo al que le guste
precisamente seguir las reglas
establecidas no no importa si hablamos
de las elecciones de ucrania de la
transparencia respecto a su positivo en
coronavirus o de su corporación
empresarial con el paso de los años
donald tramas construido en torno a su
figura una imagen de hombre de éxito el
mismo os ha descrito una y otra vez como
una empresa de un modelo capaz de
conseguir todo lo que se propone aunque
para ello pues tengan que saltarse las
reglas establecidas una especie de rey
midas capaz de convertir en oro todo lo
que toca un hombre de negocios imbatible
la mejor representación del éxito
norteamericano de hecho fue precisamente
este uno de los argumentos que más
utilizó durante su candidatura en 2016
una y otra vez prometió que llevaría el
despacho al su exitosa y probada
capacidad de gestión que gestionaría el
gobierno con la misma destreza con la
que había gestionado siempre su imperio
ahora bien la pregunta que podemos
hacernos es qué hay de verdad en todo
esto
amigos a finales de septiembre del 2020
el new york times' hizo pública una
minuciosa investigación que analiza más
de 20 años de información fiscal tanto
del presidente como de su entramado
empresarial ha sido la investigación que
con mucha diferencia más ha penetrado en
las profundidades del entramado
empresarial del 45º presidente de los
eeuu de américa una corporación formada
por más de 500 sociedades los resultados
de esta investigación han puesto sobre
la mesa una enorme recopilación de
mentiras y engaños tráfico de
influencias malas taxis malas
inversiones y una más que clara sospecha
sobre el uso recurrente de trucos y
artimañas service distribution y esto es
lo importante no siempre legales para
reducir o evadir el pago de impuestos si
es que amigos según la información
recopilada por el new york times el
presidente trump a pesar de su inmensa
fortuna apenas pagó 750 dólares en
impuestos en 2017 otros 750 dólares en
2016 y durante 10 de los 15 años
anteriores no pagó absolutamente nada
pero y ahí no acaba todo la
investigación también revela cómo las
finanzas de donald trump podrían estar
sufriendo como consecuencia de las
enormes deudas contraídas y los malos
el grupo empresarial todo esto a pesar
de que muchas de sus propiedades se han
convertido en una especie de bazares de
influencia que hacen dinero con grupos
de presión lobbies empresas o gobiernos
extranjeros que alquilan sus propiedades
para quedar bien con la familia trapp
[Música]
claro es que hablamos del presidente
como no todo el mundo quiere estar cerca
del presidente todos quieren hacerle
favores y en el caso de donald trump eso
podría suponer ni más ni menos que hacer
negocios con sus empresas ahí está por
ejemplo el caso del club mar a lago
cuyos ingresos se dispararon gracias a
la candidatura de trump los ingresos
derivados de la cuota de inscripción en
el club se multiplicaron por 10 en 2016
y eso antes de que en enero del 2017 la
familia tram doblará el precio de la
cuota esto le ha permitido al presidente
cosechar 26 millones de dólares
adicionales entre los años 2015 y 2018
y por supuesto no es el único ejemplo
que podemos encontrar hay muchos más
[Música]
américa
estoy hablando de empresas con problemas
legales y administrativos como la
farmacéutica walgreens o la empresa de
ingeniería a tim que ha alquilado a
precio de oro espacio las propiedades de
trump justo cuando estaban teniendo
problemas con la administración o
incluso gobiernos extranjeros como de
turquía celebrando y cancelando actos en
instalaciones propiedad de donald trump
en función pues de como marchas en las
relaciones entre ambos países pero un
momento vamos a ver aunque todas esas
cosas puedan resultar nos 16 sospechosas
controvertidas o polémicas lo cierto es
que podríamos llegar a verlas casi casi
como algo normal al fin y al cabo donald
trump es un empresario del sector
inmobiliario sin embargo esto no es más
que una gota en el océano de
controversias que ha revelado la
investigación de new york times' amigos
en este vídeo vamos a repasar cuáles son
las principales claves ya ha desvelado
esta investigación y cómo encajan con la
imagen que casi todos tenemos o hemos
tenido del presidente drama nuestra
intención es simplemente acercarnos a
este trabajo y bien lo primero lo
primero de todo es saber dónde comenzó
todo como logro donald trump su inmensa
fortuna atentos
el origen del imperio habitualmente
donald trump presume de ser un hombre
hecho a sí mismo un reflejo del sueño
norteamericano un hombre convertido en
una máquina de hacer dinero gracias a su
destreza con los negocios pero es esto
cierto o al menos es completamente
cierto donald trump es hijo de tres
tramp un promotor inmobiliario de nueva
york y de una inmensa fortuna valorada
en más de mil millones de dólares de hoy
esta forma a los tres años el presidente
trampa nabai a doscientos mil dólares
cada año si a los ocho años ya era
millonario ya los diecisiete recibió
como regalo parte de la propiedad de un
edificio de 52 apartamentos cuando se
graduó en la universidad que recibía un
millón de dólares anuales de su padre
una cifra que no dejó de aumentar fred
tran comentó a su hijo donald le han
empleado administrador propietario
banquero y consultor dentro de la
empresa familiar con el objetivo
probable de transferir así parte de su
riqueza mediante sueldos sin pagar el
impuesto de donaciones asimismo de un
préstamo tras otro sin que muchos de
ellos llegarán nunca de volverse
de transferible acciones y propiedades
por debajo de su valor puso dinero en
sus negocios incluso le pagaba el chofer
en total se estima en al menos
cuatrocientos trece millones de dólares
la fortuna que donald trump recibió de
su padre
ahora bien sería injusto decir que toda
la fortuna de trump valorada por forbes
en unos 2.000 millones de dólares
procede de su padre
con el dinero que le fue dando su padre
trump hizo lo que ha solido hacer
siempre se endeudó hasta las cejas
cientos y cientos de millones de dólares
para construir su imperio activos
inmobiliarios como la trampa where el
hotel plaza omar halago inversiones
especulativas en bolsa un equipo de
fútbol los casinos de atlantic city e
incluso se hizo por algo más de 350
millones de dólares de la época con su
propia empresa de transporte aéreo la
transat el amigos a finales de la década
de los 80 atrás se sentía como un
auténtico rey o un rey eso sí al que las
deudas le llegaban hasta el cuello
hablamos de más de tres mil
cuatrocientos millones de dólares la
mayoría de ellas materializadas por
cierto en bonos basura con altísimos
tipos de interés una situación de hecho
que poco después conduciría a sus
empresas a verse envueltas en una
sucesión de varias quiebras que
terminaría costándole a los inversores a
los accionistas y a los socios que
confiaron entrar unos mil quinientos
millones de dólares aunque curiosamente
tal y como veremos tran siempre salió
relativamente bien parado cobraba
generosamente de las empresas aunque
éstas no les fuera bien desviaba fondos
para sufragar otros proyectos y limitar
su responsabilidad mediante complejas
estructuras financieras así es cómo
levantó lo que hoy se conoce como la
corporación trampa
esto nos lleva directamente a una
pregunta cómo ha sido el trabajo
empresario cuál ha sido su desempeño
realmente se convirtió en una máquina de
hacer dinero atentos
racing
[Música]
en empresario
veréis si algo encumbró a donald trump
al estrellato eso fue sin lugar a dudas
el programa de televisión 'el aprendiz'
con un programa de televisión en el que
los concursantes compiten por
desarrollar el mejor proyecto en el seno
de una empresa o una propiedad de trump
en el caso de los eeuu un software que
el magnate norteamericano se presentaba
a sí mismo como un negociador invencible
el mejor de todos el hombre de negocios
que siempre lograba el trato que se
proponía y hacía dinero muchísimo dinero
claro que la realidad era algo diferente
ojo no lo digo yo nos lo cuenta el
propio trump juego con las fantasías de
la gente la gente quiere creer que algo
es lo más grande lo más valioso y lo más
espectacular yo lo llamo hipérbole voraz
es una forma inocente de exageración y
una forma muy efectiva de promoción
donald trump en la wta el arte de la
negociación y es que veréis corrían los
primeros años del nuevo siglo cuando el
productor de televisión británico mark
burnett le propuso la idea de producir
el reality show el aprendiz por aquel
momento atrás no atravesaba por sus
mejores momentos tras varias quiebras en
sus negocios principales
el imperio parecía verse abajo caminamos
por las oficinas y vimos muebles
astillados vimos un imperio desmoronado
a cada paso nuestro trabajo era hacer
que pareciera loco
y el productor del aprendiz en
declaraciones a new yorker sin embargo
ese programa de televisión cambiaría el
curso de los acontecimientos
[Música]
el programa fue todo un éxito que
disparó la popularidad de donald trump
según los datos fiscales comprobados por
el 'new york times' ganó durante el
tiempo que piloto el programa 197
millones de dólares pero eso no es todo
además como su popularidad estaba por
las nubes las marcas se peleaban por
utilizar la imagen que el tram no
rechazaba prácticamente ningún
ofrecimiento para poner su nombre a un
producto o hacer publicidad o tel
escritas galletas filetes vodka juegos
de mesa colonias detergentes ropa
interior e incluso licenció su nombre
para sacar una línea de colchones que
les supuso cerca de 15 millones en total
se calcula que trancan o por lo menos
230 millones de dólares con todos estos
patrocinios que estaban directamente
ligados a la enorme popularidad que
había cosechado con el programa de
televisión un programa que entre unas
cosas y otras engordaron la cartera de
trump en más de 420 millones de dólares
probablemente hablamos del mejor negocio
de toda su vida
[Música]
claro que no sólo hubo colchones
corbatas o colonias también otros
productos digamos más cuestionables por
ejemplo tran promoción o empresas
basadas en esquemas ponzi o sistemas
piramidales vendió cursos sobre cómo
hacerse millonario e incluso montó una
especie de universidad que al final tuvo
que cerrar ante numerosas denuncias de
fraude e incluso una demanda de la
fiscalía general de nueva york con un
proceso que se terminó por cierto con un
acuerdo por el que transfirió obligado a
pagar 25 millones en indemnizaciones
algo similar por cierto a lo que también
pasó después con la fundación donald
trump que se tuvo que disolver tras una
demanda de la fiscal general de nueva
york bárbara underwood por uso indebido
claro y es que a ver la verdad la verdad
lo que sí que la verdad es que la
historia limpia limpia no fue
[Música]
tampoco tuvo muchos reparos en asociarse
con personas como decirlo de dudosa
reputación por ejemplo en nueva york se
asoció estrechamente con te fin haría un
ex funcionario de la era soviética en
kazajistán cuya mano derecha era félix
shutter un emigrante ruso que tenía
vínculos con la mafia antecedentes
criminales no importaba france días un
hombre encantado para que lo pusieran a
los edificios de estos promotores cuyas
fuentes de financiación no estaban
claras seguro que os podéis hacer una
idea
otro conocido escándalo fue el que
ocurrió en baja california donde
transferido su nombre y su imagen para
comercializar y dar nombre a un complejo
de apartamentos de lujo una operación
que saldó con 32 millones desaparecidos
y montones de denunciadas por fraude
contra los promotores y contra la propia
familia trampa andan a tramp en mexico
por fraude fiscal en proyecto
inmobiliario fallido en fin el caso es
que con todo este dinero que obtuvo de
la televisión trump no sólo puso en
orden sus cuentas sino que tal y como
hizo con el dinero de su padre repitió
el proceso es decir volver a emitir
mucha deuda para poder hacerse con
grandes activos inmobiliarios hoteles y
sobre todo en este caso campos de golf
11 nuevos campos de golf pasaron a
integrar la corporación trump
[Música]
el problema es que tal y como ocurrió
durante la década de los 90 las empresas
detrás no generan beneficios por ejemplo
desde el año 2000 sus campos de golf han
registrado más de 300 millones de
dólares en pérdidas otro ejemplo del en
washington que fue inaugurado en 2016
cosechó en dos años 55 millones de
pérdidas de hecho entre sus pocos
activos rentables está la planta web y
mara lago la hoja de resultados del
resto de negocios deja bastante que
desear
amigos trump es un gran comunicador sabe
llegar como no había su público y ha
tenido la capacidad de aprovecharlo para
hacer mucho dinero con su imagen pero
como empresario y gestor pues bueno eso
ya es otra cosa de hecho aunque las
actividades de tram van mucho más allá
del dinero familiar existe un debate
sobre ese trabajo no le hubiera ido
mejor invirtiendo todo el dinero que le
dio su padre en la bolsa norteamericana
la rentabilidad del s p500 durante el
mismo tiempo parece haber sido más alta
que las cosechadas por los negocios de
trap pero creo que lo mejor para conocer
la faceta de empresarios de donald que
se echan un vistazo se topa en atlantic
city atentos
[Música]
la catástrofe de atlantic city amigos un
tiempo en el que donald trump controlaba
la industria del juego de atlantic city
y controlaba tres de los mayores
complejos de la ciudad incluyendo por
cierto el taj mahal que fue inaugurado
en abril de 1990 como el casino más
grande de todo el mundo trabajan
financió esas operaciones con mucha
deuda la mayoría bonos basura con tipos
de hasta el 14% anual de los 3400
millones de dólares que arrastraba la
organización tram en aquella época 1300
millones correspondían a los tres
casinos de atlantic city esto hizo que
en 1991 apenas un año después de ser
inaugurado tuviera que declararse en
quiebra el mismísimo casino taj mahal
quiebra a la que unos meses después se
sumaron los otros dos casinos
controlados por trampa el tram plaza y
el trancas él fue la primera gran
quiebra del grupo trump se vio obligado
a ceder el 50 por ciento de sus acciones
a los acreedores a cambio de que éstos
aceptaran reducir los tipos y aplazar
los pagos
no
de esta forma las actividades de los
casinos continuaron pero no por ello
desaparecieron los problemas en 1995
ante una inminente nueva quiebra el
magnate neoyorquino y más tarde
presidente de los eeuu creó la trampa
hotels and casino resort una empresa que
controlaba el tram plaza y que sacó a
bolsa mediante una ampliación de capital
la empresa recaudó 140 millones de
dólares y aprovechó para emitir otros
155 millones en bonos basura a un tipo
de interés del 15 5% a partir de aquí lo
que se produjo fue un modo de gestión
que muchos expertos no dudarían en
calificar como deshonesto y engañoso
para los accionistas trampa utilizó los
300 millones recaudados por la nueva
empresa para saldar préstamos que él
había avalado personalmente
y eso no es todo un año más tarde esta
empresa ante grandes anuncios con el
tiempo pues se demostraron engañosos
llevó a cabo una nueva ampliación de
capital y además emitió otros mil 100
millones en bonos basura con ese dinero
la empresa continuó cancelando préstamos
garantizados por trump aunque éstos
tuvieran mejores condiciones que los
bonos basura con los que financiaban la
cancelación además le dio un bonus de 5
millones al propio donald por su
productividad y también adquirió los
otros dos casi nuevos controlados
personalmente por trump a un precio que
muchos accionistas considerando
descargados la operación terminó como no
en los tribunales estaban también se
concedió préstamos a sí mismo y a pesar
de que la empresa iba de mal en peor
seguía cobrando una generosa retribución
como presidente del consejo además de un
pago de unos dos millones de dólares
anuales por utilizar el nombre trump en
los casinos incluso hizo que la empresa
ampliará oficinas en la mismísima
tratado y no precisamente a precio de
ofertas
de esta forma para el año 2003 había
perdido el 80 por ciento de su valor en
bolsa pero eso no iba a ser lo peor la
trama hotel sun casino resort se declaró
en quiebra en 2004 y luego otra vez en
2009 la empresa nunca ganó dinero y poco
a poco fue perdiendo mercado y sus
hoteles faltos de mantenimiento no
podían hacer frente a la competencia
en total los accionistas y acreedores
que confiaron entran perdieron más de
1500 millones de dólares por la mala
gestión y el mal rumbo que había seguido
la compañía cuyas direcciones se tomaban
más pensando el trump que en el interés
de la compañía los accionistas o incluso
los empleados
[Música]
por supuesto a pesar de haber sacado
mucho dinero el presidente pues tampoco
es el libro de este desastre pero justo
en 2004 se puso en marcha el aprendiz
donde trump se presentaba como un
exitoso empresario que salía a hacer
negocios mejor que nadie amigos esta es
la historia que ahora conocemos el
imperio dragón
eso sí una cosa hay que reconocerle
trump ha sabido gestionar su
comunicación como nadie
utilizó el dinero de su padre para
lograr una imagen pública que no solo le
permitía hacer negocios y dinero sino
también convertirse en una de las
personas más admiradas de norteamérica y
terminar pasando a los libros de
historia como presidente de los eeuu
claro que por el camino como habéis
visto fue dejando metafóricamente
hablando claro muchos cadáveres
corporativos y muchos pozos trampa es un
showman de primera pero un buen
empresario eso siendo muy generosos
diremos que no está claro pero por el
momento stop se ha hablado mucho de
impuestos es que acaso no paga impuestos
pues atentos
porque tram no paga impuestos
lo habéis visto trump es un tipo que
juega en el límite cuando no sobrepasa y
eso con los impuestos pues no iba a ser
diferente durante diez de los últimos
diecisiete años la corporación tram no
ha pagado impuestos sobre la renta 2 los
beneficios y en 2016 y 2017 apenas pagó
750 dólares la pregunta es cómo demonios
puede ser eso pues amigos existen dos
motivos primero que muchos de sus
negocios tal y como habéis visto no
generan beneficios sino pérdidas y si no
gana dinero pues claro no pagas y
segundo porque si trump destaca por algo
es precisamente por rodearse de buenos
asesores fiscales aunque eso no siempre
signifique cumplir la ley o al menos
digamos que hay dudas razonables
deducciones cuestionables valoraciones
ficticias reembolsos indebidos pagos por
consultoría que no se entienden bien
hablar de impuestos y la corporación
trans supone hablar de todo un
galimatías fiscales
por ejemplo en 2010 tran solicitó a la
administración tributaria un reembolso
agarrados a la silla de 70 millones de
dólares gracias a las pérdidas
declaradas con sus operaciones en
atlantic city sin embargo el problema es
que ahora existen serias dudas sobre si
esa petición de reembolso que se produjo
estuvo bien construida esa operación ha
sido habilitada por el servicio fiscal y
ahora está en manos de una comisión del
congreso puede que trump tenga que
devolver todo ese dinero más un montón
de intereses por no haberlo solicitado
debidamente
luego otro asunto delicado es que en sus
declaraciones de impuestos trae me
incluye como deducible un montón de
cosas que no está claro que no sean de
uso personal por ejemplo los aviones los
clubes de campos sus mansiones incluso
la peluquería prácticamente todo lo
utiliza para deducirse impuestos ahí
está por ejemplo el caso de seven spring
una enorme propiedad de 80 hectáreas con
una mansión de casi 5 mil metros
cuadrados con tres piscinas pues bien
oficialmente los planes la consideran
como un bien de inversión con lo cual la
corporación se deduce cualquier gasto
que se realice en ella aunque sea
cambiar una bombilla además de la
amortización sin embargo a la hora de la
verdad de por decir si no más que una de
las residencias de la familia rojo que
no hablamos de calderilla son más de dos
millones de dólares ahorrados en
impuestos
[Música]
otro ejemplo lo tenemos con los abogados
eran se ha reducido el coste de los
abogados incluso cuando le han defendido
por cuestiones personales algo que por
supuesto pues no está permitido en fin
son sólo un par de ejemplos de cientos y
cientos que explican por qué trampa
apenas ha pagado impuestos durante las
últimas décadas amigos éstos son los
entresijos del imperio trump una
corporación dirigida por el 45º
presidente de los estados unidos cuyas
intimidades o más bien cuyas sombras
ahora han salido a la luz gracias al
extraordinario trabajo que ha
desarrollado el 'new york times' nuestra
intención con este vídeo ha sido simple
y llanamente verter luz y darte a
conocer los principales puntos de este
trabajo pero llegados a este punto que
os parece si nos dejáis vuestras
impresiones sobre toda esta historia en
los comentarios y por supuesto ya sabéis
si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like suscribiros a visual político
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]